[Музика]
привіт, мене звати Наталія Супова, і
настав час для нашого уроку англійської мови,
тому я сподіваюся, що ви всі залишайтеся здоровими та
щасливими,
звичайно, тому що ми багато займалися спортом
і багато говорили про
про здорову їжу, і
ми продовжуємо говорити про їжу сьогодні,
перш ніж почати, давайте згадаємо або перевіримо,
що ми робили на попередньому уроці, ви
навчилися готувати домашнє тірамісу,
а тепер ви знаєте, в чому
різниця між домашнім і
готовим
тірамісу, ми
ми пережили багато продуктів, і ми
розділили їх на різні групи,
ми вивчили харчову піраміду, і ми знаємо,
скільки слуг
з цієї їжі ми повинні їсти, щоб бути
здоровими,
і ми навіть
дізналися про тарілку добре їсти,
як  щоб заповнити
цю тарілку корисним продуктом
, і я сподіваюся, що ви зробили
домашнє завдання,
давайте перевіримо, щоб ваше завдання було
завершити речення цими словами
хліб чіпси яйця
морозиво сік м'ясо
молоко і помідори добре давайте
перевірте це добре перше речення
ми отримуємо молоко від корів так ви маєте рацію
ви робите чіпси з картоплі добре
вам потрібно м'ясо помідори та хліб, щоб
зробити гамбургер так це правильно
ви можете зробити сік з апельсинів
курка дає нам яйця
і останнє речення  я люблю морозиво
влітку
, бо холодно, гарна робота, другим завданням
було зробити свою власну
тарілку для харчування, вибачте, їжте добре блюдо,
це моя тарілка для харчування, подивіться на це,
тому я поклав продукти, які я
їм кожен день, і це зображення  з
моєї тарілки, що ми бачимо тут,
найбільша частина моєї тарілки - це зерно
я їм багато картоплі хліб піца рис
і макарони мені дуже подобається,
я також це приблизно 30 відсотків
від усієї кількості
я також їм багато  риба, м’ясо,
горіхи та курячі білки,
я їм фрукти
та овочі, але, як бачите,
я не дуже хотів би
збільшити цю кількість, щоб їсти більше,
і я люблю, я люблю їсти йогурт, молоко та
сирні щоденні продукти, ви бачите,
що приблизно стільки ж приблизно  20
22 25 йдеться про с  Аме,
і це дуже хороша новина, що я
їм дуже мало
шкідливої їжі, можливо, іноді нечасто їжу торт, трохи солодкого шо
оладу, то
у це моя та
ілка, і я бачу, що мені потрібно їсти бі
ьше фруктів і овочів, щоб бути здоровим, ал
е великих питань ба
ато  знаків питання,
чого не вистачає, чого не вистачає в цій
тарілці,
чого не вистачає в цій тарілці, чого ми
ще не
згадали  тіло
нам потрібна вода, щоб наш шлунок
перетравлював їжу, і нам також
потрібна вода, щоб наш мозок думав,
тому що
70 частин мозку - це вода,
а все
тіло має 70 води,
це дуже важливо для нашого здоров'я і
більше того, ми  нам потрібно більше води,
коли ми займаємося спортом, коли ми займаємося спортом,
ми втрачаємо воду, тому нам потрібно
пити більше, це дуже важливо,
коли ми займаємося спортом, а коли жарко, ми
втрачаємо воду через шкіру,
ця вода в організмі називається пітом,
що"  Чому ми маємо антиперспірант,
спеціальний засіб проти поту.
Добре,
коли ми втрачаємо багато води, ми відчуваємо втому,
а іноді навіть у нас
може болити голова. Ось чому так
важливо пити воду щодня скільки води
шість вісім склянок води на день
шість вісім  склянки води в день ось
скільки води ми повинні пити щодня
, а тепер давайте прочитаємо речення й
обведіть правильні слова, як ми
зрозуміли текст інформація
частина або
весь мозок вода ваш варіант
деякі це невелика частина  більшість це
більша частина, і
все це цілий мозок
- це вода так, більшість сімдесят відсотків, це
більше половини, тому
більша частина мозку - це вода,
наступна вода, яку ми втрачаємо, коли займаємося спортом
, називається три три варіанти
потовиділення
кров або схема
ваш варіант  піт так добре
наступний коли ми не п'ємо воду
іноді болить зуб,
болить голова або синяк ваш варіант
коли ми не п'ємо воду може болити
голова
так все  туманності і останнє
ми повинні випивати чотири шість або вісім
десять або шість вісім склянок води щодня,
звичайно, ми повинні випивати шість вісім
склянок
щодня, і наступний слайд дуже
смішний. Здогадайтеся, що
жаби не п'ють воду.
їх тіла крізь шкіру
, тому я хочу, щоб ви подивілися на цей
листок.
Ця листівка про молодих
сплячих і про те, що їдять молоді спортсмени,
що повинні їсти молоді так, давайте з'їмо, гм, я
описав це тарілка
для спортсменів для
молодих спортсменів, тому що вони їдять  багато видів
спорту
давайте подивимося що їм потрібно їсти
білок багато білка багато
білка
з м'яса з птиці
морепродукти яйця боби горіхи
та молочні продукти всі ці продукти
мають
білок далі
вуглеводи вуглеводи з
овочів цільнозернові
вуглеводи
вітаміни вітаміни
вітаміни є  з фруктів і овочів
і мінералів,
особливо віруючих, особливо кальцію і
заліза,
кальцію ми можемо знайти в молоці в йогурті,
сирі
брокко  Лі, шпинат і залізо
ми можемо знайти в м'ясі та бобах,
тож це тарілка для
молодих спортсменів тарілка
для молодих спортсменів, ви можете побачити, що
найбільшу частину
складають фрукти та овочі та зерно,
також є багато молочних продуктів
та
білків, тому  а тепер згідно з цією
листівкою скажіть, будь ласка,
що в молоці, що в молоці,
що містить молоко, що містить
білок і вуглеводи білок і
вуглеводи
кальцій і білок або вітаміни і
мінерали
добре подумайте, подивіться ще раз
на список і правильний варіант
кальцій і білок
добре  а тепер я хотів би, щоб ви
порівняли ці дві тарілки,
моя тарілка і тарілка молодих
спортсменів. Ви бачите,
що у мене також є більша
частина зернових продуктів з
цільнозерновими, але і
дуже мала частина порівняння з
фруктами та овочами
Ви бачите, але я не спортсмен,
я мало займаюся спортом, тому я
бачу, що мені слід
більше займатися спортом і я повинен їсти більше
фруктів і овочів, щоб бути здоровим  ну добре,
це граматика нашого уроку,
якщо я буду їсти більше фруктів та овочів,
я буду здоровим, якщо я буду їсти,
я буду здоровим.
якщо
теперішній простий плюс майбутній простий,
наприклад, якщо я їм нездорову їжу,
мене нагодують, якщо ви не
їсте багато фруктів, ви не будете здорові,
добре, давайте вправимо нашу граматику
та круг, прочитайте та обведіть правильний
варіант
номер один, якщо ви
не їж чи не снідаєш
ти є чи будеш голодний,
ти маєш обвести або знайти цього чи цього з
батьків
і цей чи цей варіант добре,
який буде твій
вибір буде так, якщо ти не їси,
якщо це просто,
ти будеш  бути майбутнім простим номером два,
якщо в неділю буде дощ або дощ
у суботу, пікнік
буде чи катастрофа
добре, як ви думаєте, добре,
якщо йде дощ, зараз
просто пікнік буде катастрофою майбутнє
простий
номер три ви не будете або
ви є  t бути здоровим, якщо ви їсте
або будете їсти непотріб f  ood весь час
вибирайте не будете чи не
їсте чи будете їсти добре
правильна відповідь ви не будете здорові,
якщо будете їсти шкідливу їжу
наступна бабуся
справді задоволена чи буде дуже щаслива,
якщо ви візьмете чи візьмете їй
квіти
добре, так,
бабуся буде щаслива, якщо ви
візьмете їй кілька квітів майбутніх простих і
справжніх простих і останніх,
якщо я зроблю домашнє завдання або якщо
я зроблю домашнє завдання, мама
дозволить мені дивитися телевізор або мама
дозволить мені дивитися телевізор добре
так, якщо я зроблю  моє домашнє завдання моя мама
дозволить мені представити просте майбутнє просте
добре, а тепер подивіться на цю картинку,
і питання в тому, чи буду
я здоровим, якщо я з'їм нездорову їжу
лише раз, чи
буду я здоровим ні, ти не був цим
відповідь, тому що шкідлива їжа містить багато
добавок, хімічних добавок і
цукру, ви можете їсти
нездорову їжу, але ви не повинні їсти багато,
вам також потрібна здорова їжа, добре,
і інше питання, це
для нас цікаве, чи я
захворію, якщо я  не їж фруктів чи
овочів, як ти думаєш
, я захворію
так, вчора,
так, так, тому що фрукти та
овочі
є здоровою їжею, і вони нам потрібні, тому що
вони допомагають
нашому тілу нормально працювати,
і ось як ми
формуємо питання з першим
умовним чи я захворію, якщо цього не зроблю
так, ви не будете добре,
і щоб попрактикувати цю граматику, давайте
поєднаємо ці два стовпці в одній колонці, у нас
є початок питання
та кінець запитання, дозвольте мені
прочитати це для вас, чи
буде нам достатньо тепло, ви
підете до  школа чи будуть хлопці
грати у футбол чи Дженні залишиться
вдома завтра, чи Джо
миє посуд, і чи буде мама гніватися,
а друга частина -
це якщо вони знайдуть свій м'яч, якщо вона
не почувається добре,
якщо ми одягнемо куртки, якщо ми цього не зробимо
наведіть порядок у наших спальнях, і якщо автобус
не приїде скоро, і
якщо вона приготує вечерю, то давайте
зберемо першу,
як ви думаєте, чи буде нам
достатньо тепло, якщо
ми одягнемо куртки так, чи буде нам достатньо тепло
, якщо ми одягнемо наші куртки номер
два ти підеш до школи, якщо
якщо т  він не скоро прийде автобус
, ти підеш пішки до школи номер
три чи
будуть хлопці грати у футбол,
якщо вони знайдуть свій м'яч, звичайно
, Дженні залишиться вдома завтра
якщо якщо
якщо вона не почувається так
, Джо миє посуд
якщо він приготує вечерю,
а останній буде гніватися,
якщо ми не наведемо спальні
добре і останнє завдання на сьогодні подивіться на
цей рецепт,
це рецепт шоколадного торта на
вісім
осіб, є інгредієнти
інгредієнти
170 грам борошна  170 грам вершкового масла
170 грам цукру 3 яйця
і 1 ложка какао-порошку і приготування
ми повинні готувати 30 хвилин і
більше
при 180 градусах Цельсія,
тож уявіть, що ви готуєте цей
пиріг для своїх гостей, і,
можливо, у вас виникнуть деякі запитання
у мене вистачить торта,
якщо у мене вдома 12 друзів,
чи вистачить мені торта, достатньо торта,
достат ні,
якщо у мене є 12 друзів, що ви
думаєте, що буде відповіддю,
якщо прийде більше людей ні, у вас
не буде достатньо торта,
тому що  ти будеш  хай буде більше людей, чи
буде пиріг досить солодким,
якщо ви використовуєте 50 грамів цукру, а
не 170, а лише 50, як ви думаєте, чи
буде пиріг досить солодким, достатньо солодким
достон
ні, він не буде номером 3,
чи пригорить пиріг, так
якщо ви  готуйте його при
220 тисячі градусів, як ви думаєте,
так, він згорить так, він обов'язково згорить
і останнє, чи вистачить вам
яєць, щоб зробити пиріг,
якщо у вас є чотири з них чотири
так, ви будете, тому що нам потрібно
лише три, а у вас є  чотири чудових
і остання сьогоднішня інформація
на сьогодні це дієта для вашого
мозку,
тому що мозок є дуже важливим
органом вашого тіла,
і, як і ваше тіло, мозок
потребує правильної їжі, щоб залишатися здоровим,
йому потрібна енергія, яка надходить з
цукру  але не починайте їсти занадто
багато солодкого,
мозок отримує енергію лише зі спеціального
цукру, який називається глюкозою, ви можете отримати
цю глюкозу з хлібних макаронів або
круп,
тож наприкінці нашого уроку у нас є
невелика вікторина,
тож знайдіть правильний варіант із  три
сімдесят відсотків двадцять відсотків або
сто відсотків мозку - це вода
так сімдесят відсотків не голодні, так
вода, яку ми втрачаємо через
шкіру
, називається кров'яним потом або соком
так жаби поту п'ють воду
через очі, ніс або шкіру
так, шкіра молоко містить
вуглеводи і жир  білок і жир
або білок і мультфільм, і ви знаєте,
що білок і кальцій корисні,
а мозок отримує енергію з
повітря з глюкозою або шкідливою їжею,
і ваша відповідь буде так, глюкоза добре,
добре, і, як завжди, в кінці нашого
уроку
ми маємо домашнє завдання ваш дім  завданням буде
закінчити речення, використовуючи першу
умову,
тому
[Музика]
ви можете знайти домашнє завдання під цим
відео на youtube,
а ваше завдання — завершити
речення,
використовуючи перші умовні, і тепер
це кінець нашого уроку, дякую
до побачення і будьте
здорові та щасливі
[Музика]
ви